[Music]  Kourtney Kardashian makes a teeny tiny  revelation looks loke hill pinks in a  deleted scene from Keeping Up with the  Kardashians the five-foot-tall mom of  three announces that she weighs less  than 100 pounds while chatting with her  sister Khloe and their friends Simon  about nearly melting on a recent run in  the heat guess what that's not too far  off from her eldest child eight year old  Mason you know Mason is 62 it's worth  noting Kourtney is in the National  Institute of Health's healthy weight  range for her small stature and the  spelt star doesn't shy away from showing  off her tiny physique on social media  just last month she flaunted her bikini  bod during a trip to Mexico we really  had the best time ever  and Kourtney isn't the only Kardashian's  sister to open up about her size Wow  look at that bud earlier this month Kim  revealed on her app that she is a 24  inch waist for the first time ever  [Music]